Originally shown as a decorative
insertion, this classic eyelet
combination has lots of uses.
Use it as a cast on edge, pick up
a neck line or an arm hole and work
it as a band, as an alternative to
ribbing or plain old stockinette.
Her.
We're using it as a bind off edge.
Start with the carriage on the
left, pull the knitting out.
Reach behind and work a
chain over the needles.
Secure that last loop.
Then free pass the carriage to pick
up the working yarn and knit one row.
Transfer every other stitch
to its neighbor left to right.
Pull the work out again, reach
behind and chain over those needles.
Free pass to get the carriage
where the working yarn is.
Knit one row.
Transfer every other
stitch from right to left.
It'd be the opposite of
the previous transfers.
Knit a row.
Chain one more time.
You might find that working the
chain behind the knittings a
little clumsy, but take your time.
And the results are well worth it.
And then bind off.